Former President Donald Trump
kicked off his 2024
campaign yesterday with a pair of events
in two
crucial early
voting states, South
Carolina and New Hampshire.
But these weren't large,
rambunctious rallies
that the former president
is known for a new approach
approach, perhaps,
as the Republican Party considers
whether it needs a new face
at the top of the ticket.
Here with me
now is Republican Governor
Chris Sununu of New Hampshire.
Thank you so much for joining me.
I want to talk politics in a second,
but first I want to ask about
what happened in Memphis
and the type of Nichols
the video that we have seen
and most importantly, the brutal beating.
Deadly beating.
I mean, I think first when I saw it
you see it as I see it as a dad. Right.
And what that father
must have been going through
watching that.
I mean, it's just so gut wrenching.
But then obviously,
I do have to transition, I think.
Okay, well, I'm
the governor of the state.
I oversee police standards and training
by obviously state
police and law enforcement.
What are we doing it at our level?
And so you want to make sure that those
there's a sense of accountability
and it's not just training of course.
I mean, what you saw there was beyond
a training failure was humanity.
And I think everyone acknowledges that.
So, again,
you got to make sure
you're being transparent.
We want to make sure for example,
all our law enforcement
officers are seeing that video,
understanding what what happened, what
where those failures really were.
And they clearly go beyond the video,
unfortunately. Right.
You know,
what is inherent within our system.
So I think everyone across
the country is taking a look at it.
But that's that's
the kind of the tough part of leadership
in terms of making sure
that you're driving forward with,
you know, the right process going forward
in the right mentality.
With your lead,
with your teams on the ground.
A lot of calls, renewed calls
for Congress to deal with
comprehensive police reform.
New Hampshire,
your state, is famously
a libertarian, live free or die.
Do you believe
the federal government
should take the lead in having a uniform,
so to speak, a
set of rules
and regulations on a national level?
I don't mind the federal government
creating guidelines,
but let's understand
what's what's important
and what the issues are in
in New York City
or in Boston or in New Hampshire,
earner in Arizona,
might be all very, very different.
What how we try
how we train is very different.
In New Hampshire,
we have one centralized training facility
for local and state enforcement.
So it allows us
when we change one of our processes,
it makes sure that it goes
through the whole system.
Not every state does it that way.
So I think the guidelines are okay,
making sure
that certain issues of mental
health and mental illness
of safety, of officers, of,
you know, issues of bail reform
and all of these sort of things,
they can provide those guidelines.
But I do believe that states and cities
and towns
really need to make
a lot of those decisions on their own.
Let's talk a little politics.
You're here.
Is it
because Donald Trump
was in New Hampshire?
No, no.
I heard he was I hadn't made my plans.
And then you said, let's get out of here.
Oh, heck no.
But one of the reasons he
became the Republican nominee in 2016
is because
he won the first primary states.
Your state of New Hampshire
Could he do that again? Oh, he could.
I don't think he will.
He could.
You know, one thing
I mean, obviously, he's
he started his campaign
after the election in 22
that obviously
had a lot of stumbling blocks
that he was trying to overcome.
He comes to New Hampshire
and frankly gives a very mundane speech.
The response he received
as he read his teleprompter,
he stuck to the talking points.
He went away.
So he's not really bringing that fire,
that energy.
I think that a lot of folks saw it in 16.
I think in many ways
it was a little disappointing
to some folks.
And even he acknowledged
it wasn't his best.
He came to a predetermined crowd,
not one of his big rallies.
And so
I think a lot of folks understand that,
you know, he's going to be a candidate,
but he's also going to have to earn it.
And that's New Hampshire
even if you're the former president,
you've got to come
and earn it, person or person.
I want to play something
that you said in your inaugural
address earlier this month.
It's not
right to tell a private business
what they can or cannot do.
It is not the New Hampshire way
to force locally elected
and accountable school districts
or town councils
to bend to the State House's will.
That's not leadership
and it's not conservative
and it is certainly not freedom.
If I didn't know better,
I would think that that was a
thinly veiled shot at your fellow
Republican governor down south.
Governor Ron DeSantis,
because he's made a point
of picking fights
with private businesses and schools
over cultural issues.
Well, look,
I think a lot of Republican
leadership is getting behind
this idea that we have to fight.
And I get it,
as in a leadership position,
you have to be willing to have the fight
But we cannot have leadership.
That is only about the fight.
I'm a I'm a free market.
Who is who does
show that they are leading
only about the fight?
Who were you referring to?
Oh, I don't think it's any individual.
I think, look,
a lot of Republicans are frustrated,
a lot of conservatives,
a lot of Americans,
independents are frustrated
because they see this
culture, this woke
cancel culture, invading
our societies and in our communities
and we need to fight. You argue that.
Yeah,
but you argue that
there's too much of that.
There is that.
There's not
there's too much of the focus on fighting
My argument is
the government is not the solution
to cultural issues
and we have a cultural problem,
but the government
isn't going to come down
with a big, heavy hammer
and solve that problem.
As Ron DeSantis doing that too much.
It's not about wrong.
I think I think the Republican Party
as a whole
just wants to get out and fight
as opposed to saying, look,
let's remember
we're about limited government,
local control,
believing in individual responsibility.
That's that's the Live Free
or die spirit in New Hampshire.
And the model works really well.
University of New Hampshire
released a new poll this week.
You might have seen it
potential GOP 2024 candidates.
We'll put it up on the screen.
Ron DeSantis is doing quite well
over the former president.
You are on there.
Speaking of that,
when will you make a decision
one way or another
whether you will run for president?
I don't have a timeline.
I mean obviously folks are talking about
but I really don't have a timeline.
I was getting a lot of time nationally
trying to grow
the party as Republicans
talk to independents,
talk to the next generation
of potential Republican voters
that right now
no one is really reaching out to.
But I think we have a lot of hope
and optimism
in a way to kind of
want them to be on our team
and they should want to be on our team.
It's not just about the negativity
that you see in the media and the press
and that they've
kind of been inundated with.
It really is about good government.
And I'm trying to
I think we've done
that really well in New Hampshire,
trying to bring that
a little bit to the table
and then down the road
if that leads into something bigger.
So you're considering it? Yes.
When do
other people, whether it's
you or anybody else, need to get in
because he's the only declared candidate?
Well, yes.
I mean, obviously, DeSantis and Trump
are the two candidates. Right.
So whether he has cleared or not.
Well, he's not declared
okay.
Not publicly declared,
but he has hundreds of millions
of dollars.
Obviously, Ron
DeSantis is looking to run for president,
which is fine.
And he'll probably win
New Hampshire right now, without a doubt.
I think other candidates
will look to get in this spring
or into the summer.
I'm surprised other candidates
I think a lot of us aren't doing better.
Right.
And there's great candidates,
Mike Pence
and Nikki Haley
and Mike Pence wasn't even on the list.
Yeah, I don't
I didn't see the poll, to be honest.
But but no, I'm surprised
some of those aren't.
So the think
that you all you
who are considering
and I'm putting you in that category
because you just said
you are aren't doing better
because you're not more forward leaning.
Because you're not.
Oh, yeah.
I'm surprised.
I'm on I'm on that pull it all, frankly.
But because we haven't
really been been talking about that,
I think there's there's
a lot of hope, an opportunity
for good things to get in and drive
the message where it needs to be
but the discipline is getting out
to the discipline of saying,
look, you're only pulling a 5%.
You got to get out.
We don't want a crowded field here.
And that's
kind of the referee of the
first in the nation primary.
I'll have some opportunity
there to pull some levers
and really make sure that we're holding
the candidates accountable,
make a good run at it.
But if it ain't happening,
you got to pull out
and leave it down to the two,
three or four.
And we'll talk another time
about what happens
when the referee is in the game.
If that happens for you.
That's happened in South Carolina.
That'll happen in Florida.
That's true, right?
Last time I
check Ron's to go from Florida,
but I'm
what I'm talking about you, Governor.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Appreciate it.